de wikileaks et risque 175 ans de prison
aux états unis
il lui est reproché la diffusion de
centaines de milliers de documents
confidentiels à londres et à paris ses
partisans se sont rassemblés pour le
soutenir
quatrième jour ce lundi en france du
procès des attentats de janvier 2015 la
cour d'assises spéciale à visionner les
photos et les vidéos de la tuerie de
charlie hebdo
plusieurs membres de la rédaction du
journal ont dû quitter la salle les
précisions dans cette édition avec notre
reporter sur place
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous il est 20h heure de paris
bienvenue sur rt france si vous nous
rejoignez alexeï navalni est donc sorti
du coma artificiel selon l'hôpital
berlinois qui soigne l'opposant russe
depuis le 22 août à sa santé se serait
améliorée il devrait progressivement
cessé d'être sous respirateur artificiel
une affaire qui suscite de nombreux
remous londres a convoqué en fin d'après
midi l'ambassadeur de russie
on le rappelle berlin assure qu'il a été
empoisonné mais n'avance pas de preuve
et moscou dément toute implication
les précisions à moscou de notre
correspondant antoine cléroux alexeï
navalni est sorti du coma artificiel
dans lequel il était plongé et commence
même à progressivement respirer par
lui-même c'est-à-dire sans aide
extérieure et réagit également aux voix
des médecins mais les conséquences à
long terme de ce que les autorités
allemandes estiment être un
empoisonnement ne sont pas encore connus
en attendant dans la presse avec
notamment une tribune dans le new york
times ou via les déclarations de
responsables occidentaux la russie est
directement responsable et doit donc
payer
des accusations balayées d'un revers de
la main par le porte-parole du kremlin
vous savez dans ce genre de cas les
discours sur d'éventuels scénarios n'ont
pas leur place
il serait étrange que quelqu'un comme
brodeur qui est recherché par la russie
pour des infractions fiscales et
d'autres infractions ne fasse pas preuve
de solidarité face à de telles
initiatives absurde
vous savez aujourd'hui il ya vraiment
beaucoup d'initiatives absurde à gauche
et à droite il faut quand même rester
lucide en évaluant la situation
je répète une fois de plus que pour nous
toute tentative d' associer la russie où
les autorités russes à cet incident sont
inacceptables elles sont intrinsèquement
absurde
même si ces accusations sont qualifiées
d' absurdes par le kremlin les
conséquences pourraient être lourdes
pour la russie en jeu de nouvelles
sanctions donc à commencer par la
possible suspension du gazoduc nord
stream 2 bien que celui ci soit terminé
à près de 95%
en effet pendant longtemps l'allemagne
s'était refusé à mélanger dit
massy et intérêts économiques mais il
semble que le tabou soit tombé à berlin
où l'on commence à envisager cette
possibilité dans l'entourage d'angela
merkel quant à l'enregistrement audio
présenté par alexandre loukachenko est
censée prouver la falsification de
l'empoisonnement d'alexey navalni on ne
peut pas dire qu'il est convaincu grand
monde les diplomatie polonaises et
allemandes impliquées selon cette
bande-son ont d'ailleurs vivement réagi
nous démentons les informations rendues
publiques par la biélorussie selon
lesquelles il y aurait eu une
conversation téléphonique entre varsovie
et berlin au cours de laquelle les
autorités des deux pays auraient
confirmé qu alexeï navalni n'avait pas
été empoisonné
tout comme le gouvernement allemand nous
condamnons cet acte honteux
nous estimons que les auteurs de
l'attentât à la vide alexeï navalni
doivent être tenus pour responsables
côté russe on prend les révélations de
minsk avec des pincettes dimitri casque
of s'est borné à dire que
l'enregistrement audio était à l'heure
actuelle étudié par des spécialistes la
soi disant preuves d'alexandre
loukachenko a d'ailleurs rapidement et
est tournée en dérision sur l'internet
russe et biélorusse et on en vient la
reprise très attendue du procès de
julian assange elle a eu lieu
aujourd'hui à londres la justice
britannique doit décider s'il sera
extradé vers les états unis pour y être
jugé
on me reproche d'avoir dévoilé des
documents confidentiels de
l'administration américaine
le rédacteur en chef de wikileaks
dénonce un abus de procédure tandis que
le père de julien assange déplore lui a
les conditions de détention de son fils
écouter et bien sa préparation bien sûr
a été mise à mal parce qu'il ya
seulement trois semaines
les américains ont présenté un tout un
nouveau document ce qui est une insulte
à la justice britannique
et c'est une tentative de faire
dérailler toute la procédure
il n'y a pas de nouvelles mises en
accusation ce nom
un nouveau récit mais cela montre
simplement l'abus de procédure que les
américains sont prêts à subir dans toute
cette affaire
je lui ai parlé au téléphone assez
régulièrement mais nous ne nous sommes
pas vus depuis six mois à cause du
confinement
l'autre jour sa famille a pu lui rendre
visite il n'a pas le droit de toucher
ses enfants c'est le touche ses enfants
il doit passer deux semaines en
isolement et ses deux semaines en
isolement ces deux semaines en prison
et selon l'avocat français de julian
assange
antoine veil une extradition aux états
unis pourrait anéantir les chances du
lanceur d'alert de se défendre
il explique pourquoi ce qui est en jeu
c'est de savoir s'il est extradé aux
états unis et ses chances de ne pas
l'être sont juridiquement forte parce
que il m'apparaît que c'est évident
qu'il est sous le coup d'un procès
politique d'une part et que il a subi et
va subir des traitements inhumains et
dégradants s'il est extradé aux états
unis
d'autre part il ya quelques semaines
seulement quelques jours seulement plus
tôt un nouvel acte d'accusation a émergé
ce qui rend en réalité la défense de
julian assange très hypothétique dans ce
type de dossier et qui fait craindre le
pire c'est à dire un retour vers les
états unis qui comme l'expliquent ses
proches seraient probablement une forme
d' arrêt de mort
alors si la justice britannique décidé
de ne pas l'extrader
il serait probablement normal quand on
regarde la persécution politique dont il
est victime
il sollicite l'asile
dans le pays qui sera celui qui
l'accueillera et dans lequel il voudra
vivre il faut que le monde entier
comprennent que s'il était extradé aux
états unis
c'est probablement la fin en fait de sa
capacité à se défendre de ce dont on
l'accuse ce lundi a aussi été marquée
par le quatrième jour du procès en
france des attentats de charlie hebdo de
montrouge et de l'hyper cacher il doit
durer jusqu'au 10 novembre
onze autres personnes comparaissaient
devant une cour d'assises spéciale au
tribunal de paris
elles sont accusées d'avoir fourni une
aide logistique aux frères kwasi et à
amedi coulibaly en janvier 2015 les
précisions sur place de notre reporter
katia technique c'était une quatrième
journée très éprouvante dans le procès
des attentats de janvier 2015
aujourd'hui nous avons examiné le
déroulé des faits qui se sont produits
en particulier le 7 janvier 2015 date de
l'attentât de charlie hebdo
christian dos de la section
antiterroriste de la brigade criminelle
est venu détailler quasiment minute par
minute la chronologie des événements et
des images absolument innommable ont été
diffusés la scène de crime dans les
bureaux de charlie hebdo un véritable
carnage avec des corps étendus au sol
énormément de sang et certaines victimes
ont été abattues à bout portant
évidemment face à l'horreur des victimes
et des parties civiles ont quitté la
salle certaine ampleur bien évidemment
des réactions à ces photos et vidéos
épouvantable de cathy richard qui est
défend le fils de bernard maris ce lui
aussi tué dans cet attentat
il va falloir remettre de l'humanité
dans ce procès
parce que ce qu'on vient de voir c'est
inhumain on a vu des machines de guerre
on a vu des machines de guerre crié en
arabe on a entendu des machines de
guerre crié allah ouakbar crier al-qaïda
et je pense qu'il va être très important
de répondre à cette barbarie par
l'intelligence par la culture une
question également été posée à christian
dos de la section antiterroriste amedi
coulibaly a été identifiée dès le 8
janvier alors pourquoi avoir attendu le
9 janvier une heure après le début de
l'attentât de l'hyper cacher pour
diffuser sa photo au public
christian d'eau a expliqué que diffuser
une photo précocement dans un terroriste
peut aboutir à des vrais drames encore
plus important que l'attentât lui-même
je vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet la
réaction d' axel metzker qui avocats des
parties civiles
je veux dire dans le dossier ce qui est
très très heureuse aux commandes c'est
qu'elle a bon dos la religion ils se
font passer pour des religieux ils en
ont rien à faire c'est un prétexte et
pourrais je dis ça parce qu'ils sont
poursuivis pour des faits qui laissent à
rougir le moindre religieux quelle que
soit sa religion
donc franchement c'est non diffusion de
la photo reste le point faible des
pouvoirs publics parce que on ne
comprend pas pourquoi alors qu'ils ont
l'information que tout le monde mérite
de savoir la presse et même la presse
les policiers voient mes clients ont
demandé mais pourquoi la police à la
photo et pas nous pourquoi on la voit
pas et serait permis peut-être deux
c'est donc ça a permis de ne pas
débattre de l'école juive a permis deux
et donc le lendemain ça c'est ça
recommençait à la surprise générale ali
riza paul est le principal accusé qui
risquent la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité a fait une demande en liberté
on écoute les explications de son
avocate isabelle coûtant peyre
non là je voudrais rappeler qu'il a
quasiment quotidiennement demander sa
mise en liberté depuis longtemps
pourquoi parce que
il a rien à voir avec cette histoire et
que par ailleurs je rappelle quand même
le principe c'est que la liberté ces
principes et l'emprisonnement en plus
avant d'être jugé c'est l'exception ça
fait cinq ans et demi qu'il est
emprisonné il n'a rien à voir avec cette
histoire et il devrait être libre donc
c'est une demande parfaitement normal
donc j'espère bien que cette espèce
d'inversion du principe de la
présomption d'innocence cédera au fur et
à mesure des débats sur la réalité de ce
qu'il est et je rappelle qu'il n'a rien
à voir avec cette histoire
voici pour cette journée très éprouvante
mais qui permet par petites touches de
faire davantage de lumière sur les
attentats de janvier 2015
et toujours dans l'actualité judiciaire
les plaintes se multiplient contre le
groupe lafarge accusés de polluer la
scène une cinquantaine de personnes se
sont réunies devant le siège de
l'entreprise cet après midi qui est
accusée d'avoir déversé dans la scène
des déchets de ciment c'est grâce à une
vidéo postée sur les réseaux sociaux que
le scandale a éclaté à l'association
paris animaux au zoo police à l'origine
de ce rassemblement a déposé plainte
elle a découvert cette pollution le 1er
septembre dernier
écoutez ça fait depuis un petit bout de
temps que la ville de paris a été
alertée que le gouvernement ne pouvait
ignorer qu'il ya des problèmes de
pollution des centrales à béton lafarge
mais il a fallu et bien qu'il y ait ce
buzz médiatique de cette vidéo d'europe
1 pour qu'enfin ce petit monde là se
réveille
bon alors il ya le coup de gueule il est
multiple d'abord un pourquoi est-ce
qu'il faut attendre autant de temps pour
qu'on se préoccupe de ses enjeux
écologiques environnementaux je compte
lafarge polluent la scène et bien c'est
les poissons qui en meurent les
premières victimes en fait des pollution
volontaire de lafarge c'est d'abord et
avant tout les poissons puisque la scène
et
d'abord et avant tout l'habitat des
poissons et nous sommes ici pour le
rappeler pour dire haut et fort que les
poissons sont des animaux aussi que
douai les sensibilités et que nous
sommes là pour défendre leurs intérêts
et le premier intéressé bien sûr de
vivre dans un habitat sa main et puis la
question de l'insécurité en france est
au coeur des débats ces derniers jours à
l'hôpital robert debré dans le xixème
arrondissement de paris l équipe de nuit
des urgences pédiatriques a exercé son
droit de retrait après une agression les
faits sont survenus dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche selon des soignants à
père de famille visiblement en état
d'ébriété n'aurait pas supporté que son
enfant ne soit pas soigné en priorité ou
deux agents de sécurité ont été blessés
selon une source syndicale
le personnel a demandé une réunion
d'urgence avec la direction de l'hôpital
écoutez à ce sujet laetitia border elle
est auxiliaire de puériculture aux
urgences de l'hôpital robert debré et
elle déplore l'augmentation du nombre
des agressions à l'hôpital les
agressions sont pas quotidienne mais
quasi on devrait pas forcément ressentir
en mileu pédiatrique
ça commence à vous de ça a commencé a
demandé il ya quelques temps parce que
je ne me connecte déjà que c'était pris
une baffe et un des coups de pied là ça
augmente d'un coup parce que c'est la
sécurité qui est censé nous protéger qui
se prend des cours voilà moi j'ai juste
demandé à ce que la sécurité au niveau
des urgences soient pris en compte et
nous aide parce que c'est inadmissible
que des choses pareilles arrive et
portent atteinte
un travail et on en vient à la situation
sanitaire dans le pays avec les derniers
chiffres du comité 19 4203 cas
supplémentaires en 24 heures un chiffre
en retrait par rapport aux trois jours
précédents 58 nouveaux foyers de
contamination ont été détectés et 68
départements sont classés en situation
de vulnérabilité modérée ou élevée à
noter 25 nouveaux décès enregistrés dans
les hôpitaux
par ailleurs jean castex était en
déplacement aujourd'hui sur le campus
paris saclay il a été question du port
du masque jean castex s'est réjoui de la
décision du conseil d'état à la
juridiction à autoriser les préfets à
prendre des arrêtés imposant le port du
masque généralisée a strasbourg
notamment à lyon villeurbanne et dans 12
autres communes du bas rhin sous
certaines conditions
permettez moi de me réjouir de la
décision du conseil d'état qui rappelle
que les orientations prises par le
gouvernement sont satisfaisants ces
orientations je vous le rappelle
consiste à prendre à la fois des mesures
d'ordre général mais surtout à permettre
au territoire
le couple préfet maire de les adapter
aux situations locales
c'est un système je le répète qu'un
marché en mayenne qui marche ailleurs
qui marche d'ailleurs dans d'autres pays
que le nôtre
regardons autour de nous et donc cette
philosophie générale cette philosophie
générale est efficace et j'insiste et je
la revendique c'est mieux que des
mesures de confinement généralisée qui
aurait des effets tout à fait délétère
et voyez à ce sujet l'analyse de marc
jancovici qu'il est avocat de christian
charge chartier de vincent ferrer scène
ce sont des praticiens hospitaliers à
qui dénonce une fausse illusion de
sécurité avec le port du masque dans la
ville de strasbourg et mes clients
estiment que sur la voie publique
surtout à certains horaires ou dans des
zones où il n'ya pas de densité de
population il n'est pas nécessaire de
porter le masque parce qu'il n'y a aucun
risque de contamination tout simplement
parce que les règles de distanciation
physique donc les gestes barrière
peuvent être respectés sans difficulté
c'est ce que nous avons peiné devant les
tribunaux ministre hâtive de strasbourg
qui nous a donné entièrement gain de
cause les libertés sont ici enfreinte
d'une part la liberté d'aller et de
venir et d'autre part le respect des
libertés individuelles c'est à dire le
respect de la vie privée parce que le
fait de devoir porter en permanence à
l'extérieur un masque enfreint la
liberté individuelle puisque ce n'est
pas la même chose de se vêtir avec un
masque ou sans masque c'est clairement
une cela enfreint clairement le respect
au droit à la vie privée
le ton monte d'un cran entre londres et
l'union européenne au sujet du brics its
boris johnson veut trouver un accord
avant le 15 octobre pour qu'il puisse
entrer en vigueur avant la fin de
l'année elle les européens eux
préviennent il n'y aura pas de retour
sur les engagements déjà pris il ya les
précisions de pierre pissavy yvernault
la crainte d'un odile plane plus que
jamais au dessus du bric site et le ciel
s'est encore un peu plus assombri
aujourd'hui avec des informations
révélées par le financial times selon le
quotidien économique le gouvernement
britannique va présenter un texte de loi
mercredi et qui éliminerait la portée
juridique de certaines parties de
l'accord dont notamment les
réglementations douanières en irlande du
nord
pour michel barnier un négociateur de la
commission européenne les britanniques
se doivent de respecter les engagements
pris par le passé tout ce qui a été
signé dans le passé doit être respectée
c'est le gage de la confiance pour
l'avenir il n'y aura pas de compromis
pas d'accord avec le royaume uni au
détriment de l'union européenne et au
détriment du marché unique et du côté
des britanniques l'impatience règne
boris johnson veut à tout prix entériné
un accord avant le 15 octobre prochain
le but que le divorce soit officielle
est que ces règles s'appliquent avant la
fin de l'année l'union européenne a été
très clair au sujet du calendrier
moi aussi il doit y avoir un accord avec
nos amis européens d'ici le 15 octobre
conseil européen pour qu'il entre en
vigueur d'ici à la fin de l'année ça n'a
pas de sens de penser à des échéances
qui irait au delà si nous n'arrivons pas
à nous accorder d'ici là je ne vois pas
l'accord de libre échange entre nous
quatre ans après avoir décidé de quitter
l'union européenne l'impatience se fait
sentir outre manche
le royaume uni reste régie par les
réglementations européennes jusqu'à la
fin de l'année
les négociations butent notamment sur la
pêche et des conditions de concurrence
équitables si aucun accord n'était
trouvé
les règles de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce appliquerait ce qui
impliquerait des droits de douane élevés
et des contrôles aux frontières plus
poussée de quoi pénaliser davantage
européens et britanniques après
notamment des moments difficiles
traversés lors de la crise du
coronavirus et pour aller plus loin nous
sommes avec claude blanchemaison expert
en relations internationales
claude blanchemaison merci d'apporter
votre éclairage en direct sur rt france
alors huitième séance de négociations
aujourd'hui entre londres et bruxelles
les discussions piétinent
pourquoi cela coince comme ça claude
blanche maison qu'est ce qui bloque je
crois que en effet la tension monte vous
avez raison de souligner mais je vous
laisse je voudrais indiquer que l'année
dernière à la belle époque nous étions à
peu près dans la même situation
nous négocions à cette époque là le
premier traité sur excite celui qui
organisait la sortie politique du
royaume uni de l'union européenne et
beaucoup pensé qu'on allait vers un new
deal c'est à dire que cette sortie se
passerait dans le plus grand désordre
est en réalité à la mi-octobre au
conseil européen
boris johnson et et les dirigeants du
conseil européen sont parvenus à un
accord
le traité a été ratifié par tout le
monde et le royaume uni est sorti
politiquement de l'union européenne le
31 janvier dernier avec dans ce traité
la mention d'une transition jusqu'à la
fin de l'année avec union douanière
alors aujourd'hui on négocie le deuxième
traité surexcité il se trouve qui a une
considérations de politique intérieure
britannique qui joue la même manière que
l'année dernière c'est que au début
octobre il y à un congrès du parti
conservateur britannique et que boris
johnson veut apparaître cette année
encore plus que l'année dernière comme
celui qui a largué les amarres du
royaume uni par rapport à l'union
européenne et par conséquent il n'est
pas question qu'ils fassent de compromis
avant ce conseil européen
peut-être après non plus d'ailleurs
en tout cas avant ce concert avance ce
congrès du parti des parties du parti
conservateur et il est obligé de se
montrer assez dur avec l'union
européenne puisque c'est là dessus qu'il
a été élu alors bien sûr les sujets sont
beaucoup plus difficile que l'année
dernière et n'est pas sûr que le miracle
se produise au conseil européen du 15
octobre
ouvrez-les que aux horizons que s'est
fixés boris johnson et que se fixe
d'ailleurs aussi les dirigeants
européens parce que il ya des sujets
beaucoup plus compliqué comme je viens
de le dire le royaume uni n'acceptera
pas un droit de suite de l'union
européenne sur les conditions de
concurrence or l'union européenne ne
peut pas accepter le libre accès des
produits britanniques sur son marché
si elle ne peut pas contrôler les
conditions de concurrence et notamment
contrôler que la politique de subvention
les entreprises est conforme aux règles
communautaires et se contrôler
boris johnson ne l'acceptera pas donc
probablement en effet il n'y aura pas
d'accord de libre échange sur la pêche
évidemment le sujet se présente aussi
comme une confrontation puisque l'union
européenne demandent un accès identique
pour tous ces pêcheurs dans les eaux
britanniques et que le gouvernement
britannique voudrait augmenter la
possibilité de prise par ces pêcheurs la
x de la multiplier par deux ou par trois
il ya donc là un antagonisme qui fait
que les choses sont actuellement bloqués
et que tout le monde dans le fond se
donnent rendez vous au 15 octobre
sur quoi également vous pariez de la
pêche est ce qu'il y a
d'autres avancées dans les négociations
auxquelles on pourrait s'attendre après
ce moment nationale dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure c'est à dire pas de
concession britannique avant le parti du
parc du congrès du parti conservateur
vous nous expliquer oui sur la pêche là
l'affrontement est évidemment totale
mais c'est un sujet sur lequel on on
peut imaginer de négocier puisqu'il
s'agit d'une variable quantitative et
par conséquent les deux côtés si
politiquement le décide peuvent négocier
et il est possible que cela se produise
en effet et que les britanniques
finissent par accepter un certain accès
des pêcheurs de l'union européenne huit
pays sont concernés notamment la france
dans les eaux territoriales britanniques
d'autant plus que il sera probablement
impossible d'arriver à un compromis sur
les conditions de concurrence qui
permettrait d'avoir un accord de libre
échange est bon et johnson dans une
intervention qui l'a fait hier a avancé
une idée qui était qu' il existe est
après tout un accord de coopération
entre l'union européenne et l'australie
qui n'était pas un accord de libre
échange mais qui était un accord qui
visait à faciliter les échanges sans
aller jusqu au libre échange par exemple
en reconnaissant mutuellement les
certifications en fait par l'autre
partie par l'autre côté de façon à
éviter les doubles certification à la
frontière et à faciliter la fluidité des
échanges mais aussi faciliter l'accès
aux marchés publics mais aussi se mettre
d'accord sur certaines normes techniques
et peut-être que c'est cela que vise
boris johnson probablement qu'il
préférerait avoir un accord en effet au
conseil européen du 15 et du 16 octobre
parce que il a un très grave problème
intérieur à l'agronomie grande bretagne
c'est la position de l'ecosse le premier
ministre de
régional de l'ecosse a prévenu que et le
réclamerait un nouveau référendum
demandant la dépendance de l'ecosse donc
bien entendu londres peut s'y opposer
mais cela provoquera de très vives
tensions
merci beaucoup clos de blanchemaison
d'avoir partagé votre expertise je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales serbie et
kosovo réunis à bruxelles aujourd'hui
vendredi dernier à washington à la
serbie a annoncé le prochain
déménagement de son ambassade de tel
aviv à jérusalem et le kosovo à lui
accepté d'instaurer des relations
diplomatiques avec l'état hébreu
ah c'est dans ce contexte que le
président serbe est le premier ministre
kosovar rencontrer ce lundi le chef de
la diplomatie européenne josep borrell
grégoire sites des différents profond et
des pourparlers délicat la serbie sera
donc le premier état européen à déplacer
son ambassade israélienne à jérusalem
alors que la plupart des missions
diplomatiques occidentales restent à tel
aviv
une décision interprétée par l'état
hébreu comme la reconnaissance de
jérusalem en tant que capitale
mais à bruxelles l'accueil est tout
autre on laisse entendre que ce
déménagement pèsera sur la candidature
de la serbie pour intégrer l'union
européenne la serbie négocie déjà son
adhésion à l'union européenne est en
s'attend donc à ce que la serbie salue
progressivement sur les politiques et
positions adoptées par l'union
européenne dans ses relations avec les
pays tiers
dans ce contexte toute démarche
diplomatique qui remettrait en question
la position commune de l'union
européenne sur jérusalem est une source
de grave préoccupation et de regrets à
nourrir est après l'accord historique de
normalisation économique signé là-aussi
vendredi à washington le premier
ministre kosovar et le président serbe
ça soit une nouvelle fois autour de la
table malgré tout ce qui les sépare
l'europe garde l'espoir d'ouvrir la voie
à une normalisation plus globale entre
les deux parties des négociations
work les négociations s'inscrivent dans
le prolongement des tél
nous avons abordé lors de notre dernière
réunion la question des personnes
disparues ou déplacées et la coopération
économique n est un mec copley speak to
aujourd'hui nous abordons deux autres
sujets très importants des arrangements
pour les communautés non majoritaire et
le règlement des créances financières
mutuelles sur la propriété
ces deux sujets sont très sensibles et
très important pour les futures
relations entre le kosovo et la serbie
et dans la vie quotidienne de leurs
populations
en juillet dernier
angela merkel et emmanuel macron avait
aussi tenté la conciliation entre serbes
et kosovars sans succès et c'est la fin
de cette édition merci de l'avoir suivi
ont fait un prochain point complet sur
l'actualité dans une trentaine de
minutes rester avec nous sur air france
a tort
[Musique]
on doit le combattre
vous avez découvert que l'imagerie
médicale qui était le coeur de votre
métier avait une dimension artistique me
suis aperçu que c'était l'art qui
faisait avancer la science et la science
qui faisait avancer là l'image est belle
mais mais en général le mal qu'elle
révèle il est terrifiant au moment du
coup vite quand j'ai attrapé bois même
la balle a dit je me suis dit mais
pourquoi j'utilise pas ma technique de
droite et de virton life a pour mon
thorax propres et pour le virus j'ai pu
suivre son évolution commence à
s'aggraver ou au contraire comment ça
s'évacue et qu'on a découvert le colis
dont sait on sait comment ils et comment
quelle couleur il est qu'on a découvert
le mal les mèches du mal en pleine crise
du courant d'un virus après avoir
constaté l'incapacité de l'union
européenne à manifester la moindre
solidarité envers des etam l'europe
une fois de plus est en crise la montée
en puissance